un club dont je fais on voit de george
bush a le seul représentant le plus haut
gradé si j'ose dire des républicains qui
est venu se tenir donc aux côtés de joe
biden dans ce cimetière d'arlington
c'était important qui est tout de même
sept représentants des républicains
aujourd'hui en l'absence de donald trump
parce que je le répète mais ça me semble
quand même important donald trump s'est
tout de même près de 75 millions de voix
37 % aujourd'hui d'opinions favorables
aux états unis on a tendance à l élu d
aujourd'hui tant les voix de soutien de
joe biden sont sont prêtes au
prédominante aujourd'hui oui c'est très
important parce que cette cérémonie
darlington qui est traditionnel dans les
faits est une manifestation de l'unité
nationale c'est à dire qu'on réunit la
nation sur le devoir de mémoire
devoir de mémoire envers tous les tous
les tous les soldats américains qui sont
morts pendant pendant les guerres et
pendant les diverses opérations
militaires donc c'est un sujet de
consensus et en effet même si cette
cérémonie et traditionnelle aujourd'hui
elles marquent ce que byden veut faire
en essayant de réunifier les états unis
et d'ailleurs leur nom et je m'associe à
6 vient d'être dit sur le fait que joe
biden soit un politicien très
expérimenté qui a l'habitude de
dialoguer avec tous et où le conte où
les gens du du du parlement du congrès
américain et qui s'est forgé des
consensus au sein du congrès donc je
pense qu'ils savent où il pourra
gouverner
d'une part parce qu'il a une majorité
même si elle est très très courte au
sénat mais l'autre part parce que et
toute sa vie il a passé son temps à
discuter à négocier avec les
représentants au congrès et qu'il s'est
forgé des compromis